hey I'm Dave Rubin welcome to the Reuben
report I've got Aaron Foley with me I've
got Howard bragman and you know when we
started doing this show I wanted to sort
of bring the lighter side of politics of
current events and uh mix it up with
comedians personalities interesting
people uh and hopefully get a a slightly
different take on everything going on uh
unfortunately earlier today there was
the uh terror attack at the Boston
Marathon and uh I would be remiss if we
did a whole week show and didn't talk
about it so I wanted to just get to it a
little bit and we're not going to delve
that deep because it's still obviously
unfolding there's going to be a lot of
stuff that'll come out in the next month
next couple weeks um but I I felt we had
to talk about it a little bit so let
let's start with this do you guys think
it was just a matter of time before
there was going to be another attack I
mean it was actually if you jump back to
to 911 the last thing we've had on
American so it was you know 12 years ago
that's a long time so was this just a
time thing what do you think Erin oh
yeah yeah I definitely I mean I lived in
New York during the whole 911 and I just
remember those months after it thinking
you know then it was the anthrax and it
just like it didn't stop and I just
remember like week after week being like
will we ever get like a normal week
again you know like you take everything
for granted and and then I was just I
mean not to be morbid but I was just
absolutely shocked that we haven't had
something uh maybe not on that scale but
you know you just every week you'd hear
like oh they can get into the subway
they can you know cyber ATT you know so
I think you know thankfully hasn't
happen you know hasn't happened before
this but it's just it it takes you right
back to September 11th and you know
friends family and it's just my sister's
a marathon runner it's just it's so like
it just makes you absolutely stomach
sick it's just uh just horrifying but
you know it is in a way to think that's
you know the first big thing that's
happened since 91 is thankfully
surprising yeah what do you think do you
think it was just a matter of time
before something I mean things have
happened internationally this is the
world we live in now okay I mean if
you've been to the Middle East you've
been to Israel you've been to a lot of
European countries you don't go into
grocery store without getting you know
magged down and and checked for weapons
and and we've been pretty immune in the
US I mean we have lots of crazy people
with guns who will take you out in movie
theaters but U which feels terrorist to
me quite frankly but you know well that
would get into the whole definition of
Terror which already we know is going to
be coming over the next couple weeks if
this was you know it seems that it was
some sort of quote unquote homemade bomb
or you know something you could have
found on the internet but you know
people were terrorized and people are
dead and and you know 150 or give or
take or injured at at this point three
dead that's Terror yeah and and that's
the world we have to live in and I I
think what we have to understand is
there are so many targets of opportunity
we talk about the Oscars and the Academy
Awards here and we say well we have to
protect that you can't protect
everything with 25,00 Runners how do you
stop you go into everybody's napsack you
make every you just can't do it anymore
right and how much Liberty do we want to
give up for freedom because do we want
to be having uh people you know security
guards go through our bags as we enter
the mall and that whole thing what do
what do you guys think about just the
way information has changed since 911 I
mean just being on Twitter today which I
was completely glued to the way we're so
intimately involved where you can see
pictures on the Fly and read tweets from
people that are there so you feel very
connected and then in another way it
shows you how how far we are away from
people because there's this very
personal thing happening and and you're
part of it but you're you're not part of
it it's wild if if we had had some of
that stuff uh 10 years ago 11 years ago
yeah I remember Ju Just trying to get to
a landline to call my mother you know
and try to figure out where both my
sisters were in New York City we're all
in New York City trying to figure out
well all right I think she's on 60th
Street my Elder sister's in Brooklyn
maybe that's it's you're just you had no
idea you didn't even know what part uh
of the city you could cross you know but
with today I don't know for me it's a
wonderful thing because you're getting I
mean you know it's horrible because
you're you're seeing all of this but you
do feel like okay uh the more knowledge
in like a crisis situation the better
even basically you were seeing on
Twitter today it's like Boston police
saying don't go in this area go like you
know and just tracking victims and and
tracking loved ones uh so I think that's
it's pretty amazing what you can do now
with social media yeah do you think the
social media can actually sort of spread
the fear you know years ago before
television or radio of something
happened in one part of the world people
didn't find out about it till you know a
ship got across an ocean now it's like
this constantly I think the most
interesting part is we get a different
perspective we're used to Fox and MSNBC
and CNN you know and that's that's the
business new or excuse me the news
perspective that we've gotten now you
get different people and and in it you
get a lot of innuendo you get a lot of
rumor you get a lot of stuff that turns
out not to be true but I guess the good
news is you get a lot of stuff first and
foremost and and you get to hear it it's
just calling through it and knowing how
much Credence to give a certain thing
and and how much not it's you know
people always go is Twitter good is
Facebook good is it bad it's just a fact
of life it just is all right well
obviously this stuff is going to keep
you know this is going to be the big
story for the next couple months um but
so just one other uh one other thing on
this how quick do you think it's going
to be before the blame game starts
kicking in whether it's that we're
blaming the FBI or the CIA you know we
still don't even nobody's claiming
responsibility again we're doing this
Monday night just a few hours after uh
this this attack occurred but how
quickly before we just get into that
pretty unpredictable okay I mean even
with 911 arguably there were certain
warnings this was pretty nobody's taking
credit for this there was no as we know
intelligence buzz on this I mean it it
so this feels a little different it
feels almost like it did in Atlanta when
the bomb went off during the Olympics
there a little more homegrown does for
sure yeah I mean when you go back and
I'm sure Intel will come out and maybe
of course it'll be a blame game and be
like why didn't you pick up this why
didn't you pick up that but the alarming
thing about 911 was there were so many
signs I mean when you're when you're
dealing with an airline like a or a
pilot Academy that people don't want to
learn how to land the plane you know
what I mean you're like oh hey hey
hey you know what I mean so it was it
was so alarming when that evidence came
out that you were like how could you
know but now we're on a different level
where you know you and Cony rice not
close yes I had to take her off my
Facebook page um but yeah it just so
this obviously stuff will come out and
everyone will you know get blamed but I
think honestly you have to say like in
the last 10 12 years um it it seems like
there's been so many good of of so many
you know times you're like all right
well that intelligence came in that was
stopped that was you only got to get it
wrong once and you're screw and that's
the thing so either our intelligence is
a lot better and it's saved us a bunch
of times or maybe it's not as good as we
think it is but either way we'll keep
talking about this there's going to be
plenty more on it and all right now
let's get back to the funny stuff so
Justin Bieber I've done about seven of
these shows have not talked about Bieber
yet believe it or not so let's do it and
he's pissed by the way I I just want to
say he's pissed at me yeah talking about
him the guy I haven't helped him trend
on Twitter yet but we're going to it
right here right now so he was in uh
Amsterdam he was doing a little European
tour and he stopped by the Anne Frank
house I'm sure you guys have all heard
this already uh he signed the guest book
and I want to get the quote correctly so
I'm going to read it to you he wrote
truly inspiring to be able to come here
an was a great girl hopefully she would
have been a
Believer uh he also tweeted that um it
was a chill day in Amsterdam that day
not chilly chill it was cool day all
right so Justin Bieber he wants Anne
Frank who died in the Holocaust everyone
knows the story to be a believer is this
my favorite part was she was a great
girl a great girl I mean here's this kid
finally he screwed everything up the
last two months have been you know a PR
nightmare for this kid he's finally
doing something right okay he's in
Amsterdam he's going to go to the and
then he screws it up doing something
seemingly selfless and just you and all
his Believers are like tweeting we don't
even know who she is anyway why is
everybody upset and it's like such an
opportunity to educate his 387 million
Twitter followers so wait before before
I get let you jumping on this so as the
pr guy do you think there's any chance
that this wasn't calculating because on
one hand you know nothing he does is
calculated he's a 19-year-old kid who I
I think is I look at as a business okay
this is a what 5075 million a year
business and I I've said it before and
I'll say it publicly I don't think he's
getting good advice I think this kid
thinks he knows it all and I think a
little humility a little respect and I
think the people who are running his
life as managers and his publicists owe
him to sort of tell him the way the
world works that dude you don't know it
all at 19 humility and respect do the
kids not have it anymore Erin Foley well
no no no one has it uh here's the thing
he has like a he's an Entourage well
first of all let me back up and was a
great girl that was that's that was
worse than the believer it really swear
God that's where my head popped off and
I've been trying to put it back all day
uh icon a hero no a great girl that's
what you say to like Selena Gomez when
they break up like she was a great girl
and Frank and Frank then you think you
see all these reports where he's like
you know his entourage is like you know
40 deep and he's got guards and uh you
would assume he is a Handler you know uh
so when Justin Bieber writes that my my
just flew off it's totally fine when he
uh when he writes that someone right
behind him uh crosses out a couple of
these words instead of hopefully uh she
would have been a Believer hopefully
hope she would have been rescued little
little white out little girl
inspirational story inspir just add some
words I mean like he like hire a Handler
what what the part I'm kind of
fascinated with this is that the the
people at the Anne Frank house they
actually posted what he wrote on
Facebook and they are backing it with no
they they're not saying that it was well
when's the last time anybody talked
about an Frank okay is they're happy for
a little attention right now and I think
it is calling you know the good news is
that it is calling attention to
something and I think last week was the
week of remembrance for the Holocaust
and I think it is important that we
don't forget and and my parents you know
were a generation that lived through
that um I grew up after it certainly you
know now part kids today are very
detached something that happened last
week was ancient history and these kids
so it's really important that we remind
people that something this heinous
existed in our lifetimes essentially is
that the silver only good right that's
the only good that he was thinking like
an Frank's going to be like Hol Up In
The Attic with iTunes like rocking out
to Justin Bieber while the Nazis are
walking down the street like it's just
it's so inconceivable having a chill day
yeah I'm going to a holocaust rembrance
she was wearing a great dress too what
do you guys make of this thing that now
all of our news is couched in
celebrities so you got Bieber and and
Frank I mean I can't even believe I just
said that in a sentence then you got the
White House literally answering
questions this week about Jay-Z and
Beyonce going to que but we got Dennis
Rodman who just announced he's going
back to North Korea is this really the
only way we can get to Young People by
attaching celebrity to
every yes the you know I I wrote this
piece on huffpo and it was called
culture of Crisis and it's why the news
has sort of morphed into
this crap that we have now okay we've
been at War for 10 years never in the
history of our country would you ever be
at War and turn on the evening news or
turn a newspaper and the war not be a
front page story you can go through the
New York Times the LA times there will
be not one article on any given day
about the war we're in not only the war
are the longest war that America has
ever been in so this is not just some
little war and it used to be that the
media you know all these respected news
organizations would give you a little
meat a little vegetable maybe if you're
good you get a little dessert at the end
now they realize that more dessert
equals better rating so you get all
dessert now yeah all dessert it's the
start fingers crossed Frost of his
downward spiral meltdown which we all
love to see at least I do take that
Bieber your spiral downward downfall is
coming all right let's move on you're
going to get the you're going to get
them after you you know when those
little suckers get mad they get mad hash
believer I love all of you people you're
wonderful keep up the good work One
Direction you're all fantastic
everything he doesn't mean it I can give
you his home
address okay uh all right let's move on
uh a really fascinating study just came
out from the University of Winnipeg uh
that indicates that people who engage in
text messaging are more racist and more
shallow than people who do not uh the
study observed 2300 psychology students
for three years and let's uh let's take
a look at some of the numbers
here okay so people that sent 100 text
messages per day were 30% less likely to
concern themselves with living ethical
lives and 50 text messages or less you
were far more likely to care about
living principled lives so this is a
pretty this is a pretty obvious thing
here you text you don't care about
anybody Erin how often do you text we've
texted you're not an over texter just
the right amount I think I text 3,000
text messages a day and I only like
white people um no it's this is the most
ridiculous Story one count as a text I
mean if you ask me a question I respond
you respond respond those are texts
that's yes each one is one text first of
all uh does Winnipeg have any other
races it's just cold white people
texting about people they've probably
never seen this was not the right
University there's an esimo there
there's an Inuit there just stop maybe
they're anti- Inuit but it's also
college kids leading ethical lives no
one should lead a ethical life in their
20s yeah come on they should question
this is this just because young people
no you're talking outrageous numbers
people do a 100 text messages a day are
not living their life they are not in
the moment they're living a virtual life
on their phone that has nothing isn't
everyone doing that I mean we can say
that but isn't that what the kids are
all doing I mean they're tweeting and
texting all day I mean it drives me
crazy that you're at a you're at some
event or you're at some party and you
know my nephew's perfect example they're
in the corner texting somebody and it's
like put your phone down and just be in
the moment now we know that everyone
that has their their phone on texting
are horrible racist along with
absolutely being so rude they're rude
and they're racist right before you just
thought they didn't want to and they
don't care about people and they just
don't care they have no manners and
they're uh they hate asian-americans
yeah I didn't see that they like I don't
care if I run over people they're
driving because they're probably not
white people so it's okay do you think
some of this though has to do with the
technology of it because you're you're
literally disconnecting from the actual
room that you're in as you said you're
in the phone and not surrounded with
people so you're more callous you say
things on texts or in an email that you
would never say to someone to their face
right don't you do that all the time
it's it's much easier to be cold or mean
in a
text yeah I mean it's just comment there
it's so it's just absolutely the whole
study I think is absolutely just so
ridiculous to me that you can get like
racial profiling from people that are
just like on their texts and Winnipeg I
don't know I don't I think I'm going to
need a couple other studies to you want
some more numbers I hate gingers I hate
gingers that's what they hate in
Winnipeg yeah no red heads for Howard
all right all right well I think some of
them are cute it's okay no you can get a
lot you can get away with a lot more in
text and you know I can I can see this
notion and I always tell people don't
put it in writing you're going to get
nailed for oh that's funny so on one
hand you can say a lot worse things
because it's easier than looking someone
in the eye and saying something bad to
them but on the other hand you're right
you're leaving that digital footprint
which will create all kinds of other
problems General portray us hello yeah
so do you you tell all your clients
clear off the off the digital space is
that I had one of my clients showing me
these hot nude pictures of her new
boyfriend I said that's really hot now
delete it you know but nothing's ever
truly deleted is it nothing is TR ever
truly deleted every keystroke is
recorded is I tell my clients if the
head of the CIA can't keep his computer
a secret you can't keep yours a secret
did he really try to keep it he had like
a Gmail no but you know what he did you
know what he did they had a Gmail
account but they never sent emails they
would write a draft in code and put it
no they would write a draft and put it
in the draft folder and they thought
well we're never sending it so there's
no Trail wrong and how this man is
responsible for the safety of the
country he's like I'll put some drafts
in Gmail like it's like so ridiculous
but there's got to be something more
secure than Gmail I can feel them
10-year-old kid knows how to get more
like secure than a draft and Gmail no
I've heard a lot of interesting ways
that people do it I I heard of a crime
um I heard of a crime that was broken
this big embezzlement scheme and two
guys were communicating through Manhunt
which is a gay hookup site and they
would send messages there and they got
caught by law enforcement because
clearly gay hookup sites are a lot more
secure than Gmail remember that okay
let's uh let's move on but we're going
we're going to stick to some of this
digital privacy stuff so uh Google is uh
launching a new service called inactive
account manager and uh this is to
protect your digital self which in some
ways now in 2013 is more important than
your real uh organic self um basically
uh if if you die uh they're going to set
up a system now that will allow you to
keep your digital properties online for
3 6 n months a year you'll be able to
have it all deleted if you want or you
can pass it along to another person that
who then can manage your uh living
digital will I guess we can call it um
does this seem crazy we're we're so
obsessed with this stuff in our lives
now we're going to be obsessed with it
in our deaths the best sentence was we
hope that this new feature will enable
you to plan your digital afterlife in a
way that prot Tex you I'm like digital
afterlife like every you're still you're
just dead then you're
like going to keep going on this need
from the coffin they're going to get you
your Twitter account yeah well I assure
you that my Tombstone is going to be in
140 characters or less because it's you
go yeah I mean is this just completely
crazy though we're so obsessed with all
this stuff and now it's going to I keep
getting birthdays from dead people on
Facebook okay yeah you know because
somebody dies and their account will
live forever but I I mean I'm I'm
involved with reputation.com an online
reputation management company and one of
the one of the programs we have that's a
very challenging program and I don't
know how Google will get over this is
how many Dave Rubin are there in the
world um there's you know probably
hundreds there's a bunch of them this
guy who's got dve ruben.com I've been
trying to get it from him for a long
time we'll talk after the show maybe but
no I'm telling you and it's like so how
do we get the right Dave rubben died and
then they're going to kill off the wrong
Dave Ruben but I always tell people
information that's online it's it's like
herpes only it's going to live longer
than you do okay it it really does it it
exists there is no statute of
limitations for online information yeah
do you it's necessary though when you
think about it if I kick the bucket
tomorrow I want all my online I don't
want anyone checking my Gmail I want to
shut down yeah I wanted to be like you
know this Gmail will self-destruct in 54
get clean C everything I don't want you
have like some airline miles from a
credit card that you still want to use
that you actually you're dead well what
if you want give it to you now you is
that even can you even do that if you're
alive are you allowed to transfer those
that's a whole that's a whole other
that's a whole other topic but what
about your public stuff so I can
understand your your uh email you want
shut down because that's your private
communication I'm to get over it when I
die okay I'm just I'm planing to let go
when I die you're letting it all go let
it go yeah I don't know how I feel about
this because I don't want anyone posting
on my Facebook page like still missing
Aon and I'm just like there are my like
it's just creepy it's creepy to me I
want it I want it uh want it wiped out
but in a weird way wouldn't you want the
people who love Aaron Foley to have a
space to come to where they can all
reminisce about your funny Cemetery
overrated it's a people don't want to
visit the cemetery don't actually get in
their car and do anything when somebody
dies though I see on Facebook it's
really kind of a place to go and here's
the memorial and it's here and you know
but that's assuming you know that
somebody in your family has your you
know secret password to to get in So
speaking of secret password so um what I
find interesting I'm not giving you my
Social Security what I find interesting
about this is that you know one of the
things they say is you can give uh
someone can be like a custodian of all
of your digital assets but God only
knows what would happen you know people
get into financial problems three years
later maybe they want to sell your
digital asset I mean it just opens up
this endless Pandora's box of it also
opens up if you have a job where you're
overseeing the inactive account manager
that your job title could be director of
digital death DD that would be hilarious
you're a triel you know every morning
you're like go to the office what you
director of digital death I'm going to
read the obituaries today yeah all right
well wonder if you had the nice shoes
what size shoes do CER Department New
York City Apartment open director of
digital death take that with you for
this uh for this seg
all right let's move on Wow we did three
segments and we didn't talk about the
gays that's crazy because the gays are
in the news every day nonstop they are
multiplying like Gremlins in water um no
we can't multiply we have to recruit
don't you know we recruit through water
much like Gremlin so uh this is actually
a positive story we've had like a burst
of positive things happening with the
gays lately uh the Mormon Church which
was one of the main backers behind Prop
8 the bad side of Prop 8 uh they donated
about 20 million bucks to uh stop gay
people from being married in California
and then of course you know they were
tax exempt organization and that whole
thing but they are announcing now that
they're slowely pulling back from all
the
anti-gay uh rhetoric this seems like a
great thing to me is this do you think
this is possibly something that they're
changing their beliefs or is this all
like political calculation we've lost
the war we may as well get on the crazy
gay num game you have people in the
seats you know what I'm saying they're
down like 5 10% of their flock or
whatever they call it and then they're
like we got to soften our St we got to
soften I'm like so like we're like just
like these degenerate animals they're
like you know and now we can be petted
uh the whole thing I mean it's good
right because anything where you have
the Mormon church that has just went
above and beyond the Call of Duty to rip
my happiness away um and now they're
just like oh my bad uh yeah you guys you
know we're not going to pump all this
money in but I like how they they
described they said although the uh L L
DS's Prophet hasn't described a holy
Revelation directing a revision in the
church doctrine yeah like one day
they're just like oh yes I saw the gays
coming out under the rocks and we should
be nice to them like what it's just it's
just ridiculous the whole thing is
ridiculous but positive I guess Howard I
sent some cynicism over there what do
you think no well I I worked on a book
um I worked on a book last year called
the Mormon isation of America and it was
by very respected author who wrote about
Mormon church and actually they're not
they're the one of the fastest growing
of the major religion I think they're
the fast you know unlike the Republican
Party The Mormons see the writing on the
wall okay and my friend Dustin Lance
Black who still considers himself a
Mormon and is in contact with the church
sort of told me you know last year that
you know they were changing their views
and you know while some people might
hold specific beliefs as a church policy
they saw no advantage to pushing that
anymore they know where society's going
and I I do think it's a political
calculation but our own people the
Jewish people um the conservative reform
sex have embraced gay marriage and and
gay relationships the Orthodox not so
much so do you think it matters then I
guess you're saying it doesn't matter
whether they really believe it or
they're just coming along for the ride
because they see the anti-gay thing as a
sinking ship so it really doesn't matter
right remember sex the city and I do of
course you
do and how she tried to convert you know
and she kept going to the rabbi with
wine and he's like I don't want you not
the Mormons you knock on the door
they're tugging they're knocking on your
door you don't have to knock on you know
and and the Mormon belief is we're going
to bring you in and even if you don't
know the teachings we're going to offer
you that sense of community and in a
world where probably we don't live in
the same city with our parents anymore
and people feel a little lost and lonely
divorce rates are up Etc church is
important in a lot of ways and and you
know they do they've done a lot of
heinous things but there are good things
they do and they do bring a sense of
community and fellowship to people and
that's a good thing in a lot of ways and
you can't and if they're less judgmental
that's a good thing no it's a good thing
do you think that on this crazy road to
equality that we seem to be on that
there's a little danger in sort of
bending all the religions to us in a way
way you know what I mean if the Mormons
are coming along and you know they're
they're saying maybe this Pope will be a
little bit better but is there a weird
like acceptance that gays are trying to
get that maybe is not necessary like it
should just be about the the rights of
equality the true you know given rights
by the government and not making the
religions have to dig us yeah well it's
such a loaded it's so loaded because
when you're trying to it's been it it's
been so hard to cross a bridge of like
being gay and then being religious cuz
all the examples of just like you can be
one or the other you know and which is
really sad because there's something
wonderful about a community I was I was
raised Catholic you know about going to
the church and and my all my parents
friends that they met in their church so
there's really this wonderful thing so
for me it's been very difficult to okay
you feel like you have to pick so
anything where there is a bending where
gay people that still have their faith
that still want to be Catholic want to
be Mormon where they can be accepted in
any way even if it's a little bit I mean
it's just disgusting that it isn't a lot
like that we're even talking about this
but since it was so polarizing before
that if there can be some sort of a
middle ground I think that's a huge I
think that's a huge positive step yeah
Howard as the as the pr guy here so with
all this stuff that has moved incredibly
quickly with the gays right I mean the
last two years last two months already I
mean everything it's moving so fast uh
is there any advice that you would give
to the gays the gays as everyone calls
them uh to really just keep this
momentum going I mean know we just in a
little holding pattern now while the
Supreme Court Bigg I think it's bigger
than all of us I I think this issue is
not going away it's we've you know the
older gen the older generation has lit a
fuse in the younger generation and they
are all about equality you know
opposition to anything having to do with
gay rights will all be gone in 20 years
cuz they'll all be dead you know the
people who oppose it it's it's purely
generational young people to you know 2
to one you know 60 70% of young
people don't do it they don't care or as
I like to say could you ever watch Will
and Grace or and modern family and be
scared of a gay person really could you
could you you might think that look at
that horrible gay person yes they're
going to they're going to do horrible
things to me what are they going to do
to you wear a funny hat exactly you just
want to get to a point where you have to
talk about this like it's just like it's
a nonissue you know like you just don't
want to have to keep beating your head
against the wall and be like no we're
normal like it's just you just feel like
every time you meet somebody you're
like exactly ultimately I think that
that's what it really comes down to we
just want to be as boring and simple and
average as you guys let us let us have
that when I used to do when I used to do
PR for the gay pride parade in West
Hollywood I used to take the media you
know they'd want to show the dikes on
bikes and the the you know the drag
queens and the guys in Speedos and I
take them to the kitchen cabinet
refinishing Booth I go look we're boring
just like you that's all we want we just
want an opportunity to show you that to
ref finish our kitchens refinish our
kitchen all right here we go uh Airlines
everyone has had it it's not just you a
new study uh the airline quality
rankings by Witchita State University
and Purdue University Aon I know those
are two of your favorite universities
places that nobody goes nobody goes how
did I the other study we used was from
uh Winnipeg and these two random but
these are legitimate studies according
to the could it be Atlanta or Chicago
you know I mean people go yeah next week
I'll get something from Harvard or
something anyway complaints about the
airlines are literally they're they're
going through the roof not literally
figuratively they're going through the
roof uh complaints have gone up about 20
20% um Le let's look at the the
breakdown of the airline rankings and
some of this seems pretty obvious and
then some of this uh I think is kind of
surprising so in terms of quality the
best let's just look at the top five
it's Virgin America JetBlue Air Tran
Delta Hawaiian and then at the bottom
it's uh American American Eagle Sky West
ExpressJet United I mean is there
anything else that we pay so much money
for that we all do everyone in the
country flies we all pay a ton of money
for it and get less of a pleasant return
is there anything like that well when
have people been bragging about airline
travel I think I in the back of the day
no it it just seems like well I mean I I
literally travel for comedy probably
every weekend every other weekend I'm on
a plane and it just seems like they're
all about the same I mean Virgin America
and JetBlue the reason why everyone
brags about them is because you feel
like the plane has been built in the
last couple of years and there's like a
TV and it feels you know there's dance
music when you're bored yeah how about
the lighting on those virgin flights
it's like going into a club is it is
it's total club and it's like when you
Bor in the bong room I love the my God
the of weed in those bathrooms um but I
don't know it it just it just feels like
honestly the problem I have is not the
airlines it's it's the people on the
plan exactly you know they're taking
their shoes off and they're sweaty gross
feet are on the chairs and this one
family they just they queued up Jungle
Book for their kids no no headsets just
so well now we're watching jungle but I
don't know it just seems like the
humanity on the plane is is lowering the
airlines are all kind text that cuz
that's kind of racist that you didn't
like
jungle do you think that that's part of
the thing though that because we're not
often locked in with a group of people
for five hours so now if you're sitting
there and you can't you know do all your
texting and all that that you're really
concentrated on this group of people
around you and it makes you a little
nuts well I I represented Steven Slater
the Jet Blue flight attended he was my
client wait can you tell people what he
did again real quick he St was the guy
on JetBlue and you know he was mad as
hell and he wasn't going to take it and
some flight flight attendant and some
passenger was mad and he picked up the
microphone and and said you're fabulous
I think something like that and up
opened the door pulled the slide and
grabbed a beer and left the airplane the
greatest worst story of all time but
here's G Escape you know we were the
gayest Escape ever but what you got to
understand is it was not about Steven
Slater it was about the situation that
was set up it was an early morning
flight I think the flight left at 6:00
or 7 in the morning so everybody's sleep
deprived everybody's exhausted everybody
gets to the airport and you know you
paid $118 or you paid $349 and the
person next to you paid $18 and so
you're mad because you found out that
they didn't oh you paid 300 I only paid
118 you're like what and and then you
you know you over you know you pack your
bags and they go it's $5 so you go screw
that I'll carry it on and the in the
carry-ons the overheads are too small so
they do it and and they just create this
system where you cannot win where where
nobody can win and it's it's it's it's
about profits it's about these Mega
businesses that are so big they're hard
to do profitable gasoline goes up 2
cents a gallon and it costs them $12
billion and I'm sorry my pet
peeve the food yeah it's like I fly a
lot I fly at least twice a month at
transcon once a month and it's
like who conceives of this crazy yeah
these odd combinations of that they give
you it's just like can I just have like
a salad with a little chicken on it
could I just have something simple and
they give you something that's so greasy
or so spicy or so you know it's just and
everything has red peppers I hate red
peppers I burped them for seven years
okay no more red peppers people Howard
hates red at the end of the day though I
mean you are waking up in LA and landing
in New York and so it's you still have
to be positive in some way I mean you
can still get across the globe in like
eight hours you know there's other
places people can fly it's pretty I mean
it's just really yeah wait there's uh
Europe yeah no I mean you know it's just
it's always it's always going to be
something I like that their positive
remarks is we're we're sort of landing
on time and the bags get to you and I'm
like again yeah no cu no one's checking
them they are literally shoving their
bags in the overhead and it's just you
you got to drink just you drink you sit
down your chair get a cocktail slip a
you know Viking in or whatever take the
next six hours off yeah is this one of
these things that's just so systemic
like from the whole experience from the
TSA I mean if you go to JFK one of the
biggest airports in the world just
everything there is so run down the
people barely seem like they're paying
attention go to Miami baby ex you think
you're in Colombia it's like excuse me
Colombians but sorry I didn't mean to
offend the cartel but it is is like the
most third world airport if you're you
know you get your luggage they've rifled
through it you know but is that is that
the thing that it's just so systemic at
all levels from the TSA to the to the
planes themselves that are falling apart
I was on American a month ago I mean
literally the hand thing was like
falling apart is it just like everything
at there's just nothing can be done I
was on an airline and like the seat
didn't go back and this didn't do it and
she's like I'm really sorry it's like I
I'll live with this I'm concerned what
in the engine you didn't fix okay
exactly right the seed is one thing well
I guess what we learned here is that uh
virgin if you would like to sponsor uh
the Reuben report it is there's contact
info right below and speaking of
sponsoring the Ruben report bonobos.com
is the official Outfitter of the Ruben
report and if you want this beautiful
checkered turquoise and white shirt I
want to put you in it go to bonobos.com
andent her code tr20 for 20% off and
let's get to The Last Story come with a
really long sleeve so oh yeah we got
long this is a slim fit we got right
here but you can get a long I will get
you in something it will be beautiful
all right here we go final story uh cell
phone contracts they may be a thing of
the past we've been doing a lot of
complaining about things the internet
and Airlines now we're going to Talk
cell phones this one might be a positive
story here uh the CEO of Verizon uh LEL
McAdam is saying he's going to consider
killing cell phone contracts contracts
if quote consumers demand it you know
T-Mobile is dropping contracts now
people can just pay for a month and get
out and the New York Times did a they
broke down the numbers and I thought
this was incredible if you were to go
with T-Mobile with a comparable plan on
Verizon but instead of Verizon you went
with T-Mobile over two years you could
uh save about 960 bucks so finally this
uh these small groups you know we got
four companies let's say that run
everything they're starting to do things
different and it might work to our
advantage how do you feel about the uh
the cell phone and uh freedom why are we
locked into these contracts uh I didn't
know T-Mobile was still in business so
when I read that article you had that
really big cell phone don't you the one
that like the size of a purse I like
when people say have T-Mobile I'm like
do you have like the rles wrap around
the eaters on the TV it
just giant um you know I don't know it's
it's it's we're getting robbed it's like
you know and then it's like a two-year
contract then your phone breaks down
inevitably and like two months right
before the contract you come in and like
you know the phones in three parts and
they're like well you're if you sign a
new contract you can get seven new
phones and you're just like all it's
just handcuffed you know it's it's
absolutely ridiculous but you're so
dependent on it it's just I literally
was at a went to a com 100 racist
comments a day I need to text people
like I hate but I literally it I I I was
going to a comedy club and I forgot my
phone and it it just it felt like the
end of the world I was just like this is
this is
insane I can't steal anybody's no it was
like the map I didn't know where I was
it literally felt like I was like oh my
God this is like this is I would rather
not have my wallet or like have like it
just it makes you crazy and you realize
how dependent you are on it and and they
have you they have even the fact that
now we know who's calling us you
remember it was only about 10 years ago
that you would pick up a phone in a
house and not know who was on the other
end now you would never do that on your
cell phone would you ever pick up aand
if they don't you have them all block
but you would never pick up a why would
I ever pick this thing could blow up
sometimes I roll the dice and I answer
it and then I'm like oh nothing ever
good yeah has anything ever good come
out of a a random number that's calling
you no nothing well I don't know about
you boys a Manhunt but I don't know how
that works but yeah no nothing for me
personally has ever yeah come out of um
I switched cell phones last week
carriers because I moved to a new part
of La okay and I had one bar and I could
not get cell phone service at my new
home and how many bars do you have now
it's like four or five it's like a
beautiful thing you want to tell us who
you switched to are you Swit to AT&T and
um you're getting better and you're
getting better that's never been said
before ever no I'm getting I and it's
like oh my I was with Sprint and they
charge me $350 to leave so I will trash
them yeah and it's like I'm really
content I'm getting service in all these
well there's a couple dead spots but
everybody you know I'm getting so much
better Serv service than I had and like
while people were working at my new
house I go who's your cell phone carrier
how many bars do you have in AT&T one
you know we we did the uh the test and
it's it's kind of crappy I used to live
in the hills and I used to live near
this hill and there were cell phone
towers at the top and they wanted to put
a new tower up and one of these
neighbors was going around saying sign a
petition so they don't put a cell phone
tower up and everybody's like are you
crazy what is wrong with you I want one
in my backyard it's like exactly it's
really like pathetic though that's like
our like I'm I know I'm totally attached
and we were literally like we'll be in
an area and like how many bars do you
like it's this is this is our
conversation now this is what we talk
about we've started the show by talking
about texting and we're ending it
talking about s but but really these
contracts I mean there's can you think
of anything else that we held hostage
the way we are with these cell phone
contracts you started by talking about
terrorists and you're anybody talking
about oh there you go exactly so no but
really is there anything else that we're
so do you pay out two years of anything
else that you do in your day-to-day off
I like to say I've reached a level with
a mortgage but I I haven't been not
quite there yet uh when you work for a
standup nonprofit company um but you
know what T-Mobile will change the
business if Verizon Falls then it's only
a matter of time it's like the airline
business and then they'll all and then
they will start charging you per Tex
because they realiz they're not making
any money on cell phones anymore and
then I won't have to be
racist you can't full circle full circle
you can't help it this show Absolutely
came around full circle I want to thank
Aon Foley and Howard bragman I'm going
to let you guys do a little pimping a
little pimping of yourselves Aaron Foley
where can they find you uh you can find
me on aaronk foley.com I have a new uh
Sports podcast because there's not
enough a sports podcast a podcast a
podcast uh there not enough comedians
doing podcasts so uh it's called Sports
without balls me and Rebecca Corey nice
talking about sports so is it it's Le is
talking about sport she's a straight
lady straight straight yes she's talking
about how much she wants to bang the
players and I do the
stats Howard where can everybody find
you well uh anywhere anywhere it's very
easy at Howard bragman on Twitter you
can go to Howard bagman.ua
we will put it all right down below me
right there I thank you guys for
watching and we'll uh do this again next
week why
not